hello everyone
20 years ago latin american cinema
exploded around the world from mexico
the names of alejandro gonzalez
guillermo del toro alfonso coron
rapidly became a reference for everyone
around the world and not just from
mexico from brazil there was walter
sales fernando mireles padilla from
argentina trapezo lucrecia martel many
names from latin america that were
suddenly setting the bar really high
there was no cool festival if you didn't
had a latin american film
names like wild tales roma fantastic
woman titles like embrace of the serpent
no the milk sorrow latin american films
have been celebrated around the globe
and especially at the academy awards but
we're not stopping there many filmmakers
are crossing over and expanding their
careers into the english language
industry
and those stories need to be heard
in the following panel the amazing
producer rosa bosch will have a
passionate debate with four filmmakers
that are already shooting in english
that have so much to say and experiences
to share so please stay for the panel
enjoy the panel
and remember tell your own stories
thank you very much diego luna for such
a heartfelt introduction
and thank you very much for joining us
and kick starting this uh academy
conversation from latin america into the
mainstream
today
my name is rosa bosk and we are being
joined by four leading filmmakers
uh from latin america gerardo naranco
from mexico jairo bustamante from
guatemala marcella said from chile and
career menus from london
this is truly a global event although
these are
leading latin american filmmakers this
conversation is conducted
in paris london
madrid and mexico so welcome to all of
you thank you very much for joining us
for uh giving us some of your time
in the middle of busy schedules uh
cobia has had an effect in our cinema
lives but has not managed and it looks
like will not manage to stop production
i would like to begin with to introduce
you a little bit to the people watching
from all over the world so if you allow
me i will go around each of you
and it will be very good to hear what
you're working on now
so cari menus brazilian-born algerian
descent
based in berlin truly man of global
mystery you are now based in london your
filmography is extensive documentary's
fiction
kareem tell us a bit uh what are you
doing in london what's going on
i'm doing i'm actually prepping a
feature film called five brand which is
the story of the last wife of herman the
eighth i think we know a lot of the
wives that perished and here in the
eighth and this is the story of the wife
who survived him so
um it's a portrait of catherine parr
that was her name
and um we're planning to shoot at the
beginning of next year
and it's very exciting to be able to
get my hands on this character and and
draft a portrait
of these women that have normally been
portrayed because they have perished and
so good to be able to to to tell this or
everyone who has
survived so that's what i'm currently
working on it's my first english
language
film really um and i'm very very excited
to to do this
well we'll we'll catch up on that much
more marcella syed chilean born
again extremely
i understand chilean balboa again we are
the four of you represent such a
diversity in latin america american
culture is an extraordinary pleasure to
have you you are actually unborn but
with some palestinian ascent i believe
um
probably as comfortable in the french
culture as you are in the chilean
one
recently we've had the pleasure of
seeing you direct a couple of episodes
of lupine with great panache
but you also come from the documentary
background into fiction
mainstream television
tell us what what's next for you what is
keeping you busy today
uh
well i'm currently i just finished
writing with the gonzalo massa
uh our next my next feature
that is
is going to be in english is called the
hanfo de puma and i'm here in london
directing two episodes of gangs of
london
which is also television for sky and is
in english
so my first time
directing really the whole episode in
english because narcos was bilingual
gerardo
mexico city
but you are
also not only known from beginning of
the
i guess mexican gang that came out of
the critics week of khan with your
drama max miss bala of course is a
milestone in latin american cinema not
only did you do the mexican version but
you also did the american remake
i'm sure
another remake sorry
you didn't direct the remake that you
produced yeah i produced
ah
sorry which is an even more interesting
experience perhaps we'll talk about that
um what are you working on these days
tell us what you're at
well yeah first of all thank you uh
you know honor to be among these
filmmakers you know uh
madame chata
karim is
you know when i saw that you know it was
important for me you know
so
i'm working in a netflix documentary
it's my first time doing documentary is
uh it's about a case where a french
woman was accused here in mexico about
being a kidnapper
so you know it's been 15 years
from that event that happened here in
mexico it triggered an international
crisis political crisis uh it's called
the
cassette affair uh so i'm finishing that
it's a five it's um four four episodes
series and
wow well what to say you know i i i feel
yes um
going to documentary is very humbling i
feel it's a lesson i will um
i will uh advise for any filmmaker just
to surrender yourself against destiny
and um what am i i'm working now in a
movie uh it's a it's a
it's a love story it's english and
spanish
uh it's about uh it's a tragic love
story and it's what i hope to be
shooting
2022.
where
uh oh my god it's uh i guess we're gonna
we we need a lot of money but it's all
over it's new york it's mexico it's the
ocean of oaxaca
um
the mexican university it's all over
it's a contemporary love story and it's
a very tragic one where you know the
the
girl in the story which is a mexican
girl uh dies this comes from a real
story the
author of the novel that is inspiring
the film
his name is francisco goldman
and
you know he's an author a great uh you
know author
and he's writing the script
and it's about you know
this very unfortunate event
so you know
very lucky to be
looking forward to saying jairo
bustamante from guatemala
i i think
you are a unique piece in latin american
city because truly in my lifetime i have
not seen anyone that with your volcano
trilogy sorry i think some of us call it
volcano trilogy templares external and
of course the huge success of la la
llorona you've single-handedly put
central america in the map
and with an indigenous component that is
really so intrinsically and beautifully
waived in uh i think since the days of
uh since the 50s or 60s of political
filmmaking there hasn't been someone
like you
with such a reach so what are you doing
in paris what are you working on tell us
what's next
hello i'm in paris and um in a kind of
um
holidays and developing because i'm just
finished my last film
um one month ago and i'm editing the
film myself with my producer
and it was a very nice story because
the shooting i mean the shooting was a
nice story
because it's relevant for for my country
and i think for the world i'm talking
about the childness and how the adult we
take care about them
and but for the film that's time it's
one when i shoot in guatemala i start
preparing the actors to be to became an
actress because we have a very small
industry in my country so
and that time
i
i arrived to to finish
the composition of the of my school
after school
and and i formed 350 girls
in guatemala she became actresses
after made a casting
for five six thousand girls who came to
participate in the film
so
it was a very nice experience and and in
six months we could
firm that actresses in a so well
way that i was surprised having them
working with me
and it's girls coming from eight are
17 years
and
and really i think
right now we can say that we have real
actresses in in my country when i say
actresses i mean movie
cinema actresses
and
[Music]
and right now i'm developing a
saga of films that the platforms prefer
to call it a siri
but it's talking about the mayan
cosmology
and for mayan people there is not
anybody ordinary each one is
extraordinary and i'm talking about all
the gifts that maya think that we have
just because
we have a now is a protectors
living with us it's a full of magical
realism
right i hope you have a good holiday as
well well deserved of course for those
of us listening you probably realize as
well if you followed
marcella's career
also with indigenous
local communities marcella so not
forgetting your own contribution to that
so anyone listening to the four of you i
think has very clear idea from what you
said
why we're calling uh this discussion
today from latin america into the
mainstream
you have all worked through the festival
traditional
ways
of presenting films into a much more
global and ambition reach
now one of the things that i'm very
curious and i'll let you jump in whoever
wants to speak first is
there is a perception that perhaps the
arrival of the platforms the globality
the globality of what the netflix apples
amazons the
online viewing and streaming has
provided filmmakers from non-english
speaking countries with a much wider
outreach
not only for the films you've made
but in the case of you you are all very
comfortable directing in french in
english in your own
spanish in indigenous
is the is this true how do you feel
of the pla have the platforms the
arriving of the platforms really given a
global outreach to your work marcela you
want to start with that
uh
yeah okay i mean um
it's very weird i would say because um
you know like if you ask me i didn't
want to be a filmmaker
like i mean i come from yeah i wanted to
do politics
and i i started doing what i do because
i have this necessity to talk about what
what was going on in chile so in
dictatorship so
so and i spent like 10 years doing
documentary films and it took me a lot
of years and i was very passionate and
then
like i feel i had to jump into fiction
my the assignment of flying fish was a
story i couldn't make i couldn't make a
documentary about that story so i had to
write so i started writing and and i
discovered i loved that and
and then of course uh
i guess i had the chance like the film
really was taken into cannes and then it
was los pero's way my real first
feature completely i mean i was writing
alone so i wrote los perros alone and
it was a very very good experience
and
and then it was
you know i used to live in france i live
in france for a long time i still i
still do i live in paris
but i was always focused on directing in
chile so when
the first time they kind of invited me
to direct in fra in french in paris it
was
uh
lupa
and i was so happy you know and it was
because after narcos i told the
production you know i live in paris i
speak french
i can do it in french and this is my my
real second language it's not english
it's french so
and
and i was so excited
because um i know the french culture is
also my culture i consider myself
chilean and french
so for me it was a massive experience
and
what it was
quite um
funny it's like a lot of people didn't
know me because i took our house films
and after lupine
i had all these people ah
so you had other films
ah you come from documentary yeah yeah i
mean it's not yes
i mean this is a le pen is working
archos is work but what i consider my
real work is what i write when you know
my next film that i'm writing with uh
gonzalo massa that i'm going to shoot in
chile
and and of course i'm going to direct in
english and also for uh for us you see
because i want to make it
global and bigger and because my
character
is an english couple actually who's
traveling to patagonia
to visit the french couple and this
comes from a kind of real story
um
so i
i guess it's very normal we we live in a
world that is globalized
we we travel a lot we
we all of us we we speak different
languages i mean karen he lives in
berlin he told me i mean so he must
speak german and he comes from also
algerian background
and and
and i don't know he's in paris but i
know he can speak french i mean
um
so
we we are globalized people and and
we are we don't want to be also
considerate all you know like because
i'm chilean i just have to direct in
spanish
spanish and just about my subjects
i think all the stories are universal
and and and we realize i mean
the good thing about netflix about
amazon about apple about all this
platform
it's like it's the same that happened to
us when we came to paris for the first
time
you know i started watching
latino american cinema for the first
time in paris
when i was living in chile there was no
distribution so i didn't know mexican
cinema i didn't know argentinian cinema
i didn't know that what what my
my people
were doing and i discovered latin
american cinema in paris
in the festivals so i discovered we we
were so much alike
that we come from the same kind of
landscape stories
uh with the same difficulties i mean
difficult things i mean we are small
countries with a very small production
it's very difficult for us
to to produce sometimes just a movie and
then
at some point and we had this you know
this big cinema from hollywood and i
remember with something like looking at
those films and say well
i
we would never do that i mean we just
come from you know and
do you know what what changed my
perception about fiction
i must say
it was when i i saw in paris la cienega
the film of lucrecia martel that i
really love and i i saw the film
and i thought this is this is my story
these are my my landscape this is my
people this is a beautiful piece of art
and this is something i can do
and we all can do i mean like it feels
very
close
and achievable
and so like yeah we can do that maybe
at that point we could you know we were
not into explosion we were not into
blade runner films in chile i mean doing
these kind of things it was like what we
call mainstream you know uh
it was it felt very
very far away from us uh like something
there's a lot of things that we don't
know how to do i mean or we didn't know
how to do even me i come from
documentary when you hirago told me i'm
doing my kind of first time documentary
like but i come from there so that's my
school
i come from this school when you it's a
very good school you you adapt
you find solutions immediately i come
from what anything can happen so i'm not
afraid now if i'm in a in a in a big you
know i'm like working in gangs of london
and with a big budget and there's a lot
of people but also there's a lot of
problems but i'm not afraid
i mean i come from latin america
everything can happen you know so i just
it's a very
it's
there's no stress for me
so uh
that's a very good school actually we
have something we latino american
directors have something that maybe is a
is a very good thing we come from this
part of the world where everything it
can be very difficult and we have a lot
of problems and everything is like we
can do a lot of things with nothing
so
when we have things we can do much more
of course
so maybe the real thinking when we
started with these was that
conversations like these can help if i
can pick up on one of your words
to let people know that there is more
than one mainstream there is only not
one kind of mainstream which is the
hollywood mainstream but we can achieve
mainstream
and the platforms and globalizations can
help us to do that so let's look at
different mainstreams karim what do you
think of the brave new world of
platforms globalization
access
i think it's just a really interesting i
feel really privileged because i
remember when i started
it was really like i started making
films when there was no digital you know
so everything was
it was it was really hard and it's
complicated and i think i feel really
privileged to be gone to have gone
through this period where it became
digital so then there was a possibility
of doing things which were perhaps more
agile when than you're working with with
um with film and then the platforms came
on in a moment where um
distribution has always been a really
huge problem for latin american cinema i
think we have
a very rich tradition and very diverse
and very vibrant but as marcella said
you know
the way that things were positioned to
the public was always very complicated
like for me too i remember
seeing much more um latin american films
when i was traveling with the festivals
when i started to make films before so i
think what the platforms have provided
which is really exciting is the
possibility of different formats in the
sense of like you know episodic
storytelling or you know the classic
sort of format of a fiction film
but also i think what's been happening
in the last years
and it's really important to talk about
this
in brazil now for example you know i
mean
latin america is very um
it's full of emotions one year you have
one government the other you don't and
then so sometimes you have public
funding sometimes you don't so it's a
very sort of you know um
dynamic landscape and i think one of the
things that the platforms have allowed
us to do is to keep working like
thinking of what's happening in brazil
now it's you know with with this
horrible government that's um there
which has decided to erase any
possibility of cultural diversity and
expression the platforms has allowed us
to keep us working but it also has
allowed us to keep us working a very
inventive way so i think it's really a
wonderful time
thinking of what we've been through in
latin american thinking now
that there is different possibilities of
working different possibilities of
telling stories different possibilities
of talking about our own um
culture and i think english language
still a very strong you know films in
english language and series are very
strong market obviously because of
the hollywood system and the star system
but i think there is also a new
generation which is making work locally
and broadcasting it globally through the
platforms that i think it's really
empowering and that's what i think it's
really um
fantastic about the times you're living
in i think we need to be of course
attentive
that we're not you know we're not
working with for the platforms but with
the platforms and you know making sure
that we still have our own voice
in our own ways of telling stories you
know that we're not sort of you know
doing things which are very homogenic
but i think it's a really interesting
moment
to um
you know you know to just work with work
with the pos with the many possibilities
that we have now that are much bigger
and much larger than we always had we've
ever had in history uh and i think also
way of telling stories i think it's very
it's very exciting for example that we
have here
um
gerardo who's been working with
documentaries only be working with
fiction who is working for a platform
you know and uh marcelo who's been
working with documentary and i was
working with fiction you know so i think
it's allowing us to to to travel between
genres and between
um
formats which i think it's really always
exciting and always inspiring so
i don't know i just feel very fortunate
to be living in a moment in history
where
there is so many
possibilities um to tell stories and to
and to
and to also tell stories which are very
local i think this is what's really
fascinating about the times of levine is
that you know look at haitu's films i
mean there's nothing more local and
beautiful and poetic than what he's done
and i think
um the platforms are allowing but not
only the platform but i think there's an
ecosystem that's allowing for his films
to exist and to be seen you know
around the world
so linking on that in fact hydro before
we also hear what you think i mean it
was an extraordinary thing to see you
building up
uh through your volcano trilogy and
culminating with la llorona going into
one of the most astonishing oscar
nomination campaigns i've seen in
in recent memory and even very moving to
see you getting the attention of the
likes of jane fonda supporting you
you must have had a really interesting
experience in terms of going straight
into the oscars campaign the jane fonda
that attention tell us a little bit how
you see
this global situation helping the very
very strong and focal identity you're
putting out
yeah i'm agree with marcella and karim
about the fact that platforms are
important for us and and
about the
that moment that period so
so unique in our history
but i don't want to forget the people
who start before us
and the people who start opening their
doors and there is a lot of actors
actresses and filmmakers who
went to that hollywood market or
hollywood place mainstream
and they start
open the mind of of
usa people saying that we are a lot and
latin america has a very good market
and and for for huge time
a long time they didn't
keep the opportunity to say
there is a market there is a continent
speaking the same language or
understanding between them even because
in spanish and portuguese brazil and i
mean is very easy to understand
and
so i think that people start opening
that and right now platforms are taking
advantage of that and for sure we have
to take advance for that
and
but there's still a lot of problems in
some regions in latin america for
example in guatemala
people doesn't have access to movie
theaters but either either for platforms
there is less than nine percent of the
people having access to the platforms
and because there is not internet
because it's because
the eighty percent of the population
live in uh extremely poor tea
and
but it that no that doesn't mean that
they don't want to consume films because
for example with dishcannell my first
film
we made a kind of a normal distribution
in guatemala
and after that we had a
an alternative distribution taking a
kind of a van and a screen with us and a
very very small song
equipment and we moved to the
communities
and we made
ochenta mili
80 000
tickets
with the communities
and it was very important for guatemala
it was the first time i made more than
in france
and and in french people
i have a good market here good audience
here and so that's a very important
thing that we have
to continue pushing
uh our energy in in
because it's a kind of a responsibility
to
if
if we cannot arrive
to that people that win
i think in my case that people need me
more
than french people so
[Music]
so
i don't want you to forget them and i
continue
for sure making a
a tv film or a platform film i don't
know what what we have to call it
um
it's important because
it's a kind of a show of cards
but
used that show of card to come back and
made another
film social work film
uh continue being very important in my
case
very interesting and the point you raise
feel free of course as we started and as
we've heard from diego the number of
people the number of filmmakers that
have preceded you it's not just
filmmakers filmmakers are the captains
of the ship but of course we all know
that without the wonderful array of
latin american dops you know from chibo
lubetsky to navarro to music supervisors
lin feinstein to writers gonzalo i mean
the talent behind all of you as
directors is extraordinary so let me
just take this one moment to say that as
they say behind every great director
there is a great team and in the case of
latin america the talent of actors uh
director cinematographers is
outstanding we could do a series of
events on just cinematographers set
designers
and even a few producers
so gerardo you are in the eye of the
storm
mexico the border with the u.s
mainstream of course mizbala being a
milestone film
which you then went on to be executive
producer on the remake
um that was quite an experience you
really went into the belly of hollywood
with it tell us a little bit about what
you think and then of course narcos and
everything else but a little bit of your
experience would be interesting
well um
it's it's awesome to just hear
my other fellow filmmakers and just uh
agree
on how hard is to begin over there in
latin america so yes when you cross
i feel you know and
my experience in latin america i felt it
was very physical making the movies you
know you have to carry or even if you
have to
even if you have to just convince people
i feel something much more physical i
think uh you know crossing the border
it's much more political you know it's
about the world it's about communication
it's about
um
yeah i feel it's um
something much more in in manners you
know in uh
how you drive yourself how you show your
character uh
so
i guess we have those
both sides you know latin american
directors or filmmakers you are right
rosa when you say that we we are
surrounded by this incredible talent
that makes uh
you know we're just the top of the
iceberg but yes there is a lot of work
and a lot of wisdom that you get from
the process of um every collaboration so
yes i guess uh is something we
you need to
put your seed and you know put the water
and eventually that relationship will
give certain wisdom to the project i
feel that's them
well that's uh
how i see it
hollywood let me tell you that uh well
you know um i i'm very interested in
producing um
you know um yeah getting to know how the
industry works so yeah that's why i
joined in mizbala the remake and it was
very interesting i guess the decisions
uh how the decisions were made were to
me the most uh you know interesting uh
event and i will mostly be a witness to
tell you the truth but uh it was a very
interesting uh diving into the american
psyche uh for my part
it occurs to me hearing you all of you
that perhaps whilst 10 years ago anyone
would have said that in order to be a
global filmmaker shooting in different
places in different languages you sort
of had to go into the hollywood system
be showered by hollywood agents
and have that kind of machinery the
agent the manager that is and by
listening to all of you it seems to me
that that is no longer a necessity there
is a different way of developing truly
international careers of filmmakers
without going into that i mean for
instance hiro did during the the la
jordan camp oscar campaign did you have
a lot of hollywood agents approach you
yeah i had my agents at that moment
and my manager and i remember that when
when they approached me i was making
this canoe and i told them i had a
trilogy to make so please just wait a
little bit and after that when i
finished like when i was
starting la jordona they came again and
i asked to carry him do you remember
karim i asked him
really i need them or not
and and kareem tell me just sign don't
worry make them work and
and it was like that
and and i'm very happy because the
people are very are really
hard workers
and they really take care about
the idea that i i bring to the table
and they don't
they don't they don't are just looking
for push me in the mainstream market
they are
helping me to to defend
the
the thematics that i want to work and
and they are
helped me to
to making to grow up in my local
industry in guatemala
and and jumping a little bit about that
um gerardo was saying and marcella was
saying about the fact that we can do
anything
and in latin america and about the the
so talented teams that we had
i want to add that we have very very
generous team in latin america and i
could leave that because all the people
that i call to come to guatemala and
work with me with me
they came and they inform my people my
local people
and that was an an
unexpected um
gift because right now we can build
a film with guatemalan people so
that i think as a as a latin american we
really felt
a kind of um
unity and
and i'm very happy for that too
so marcella what do you feel is it
needed to have a big hollywood entourage
to further your international career
because it seems like it's not the case
uh all depends what you want i guess you
know it's um
for me you
i i i i told you the truth like for me
is it's very important not to to lose
uh the north as we say in chile like to
know exactly at least what you want and
to have your heart very
you know um
so i know that i i cannot get lost i
don't want to get lost if you if you ask
me and
i know i need to tell my own stories um
that's why for me i've been writing for
three years almost like the hand for the
puma with gonzalo and it's very very
important for me just to go and make
this film next year
so i start the process of the casting
process already so i'm i send the the
script to the actors
um
and i know this is priority
and my agent and the people that what
they are they are i told them and they
know this is priority
so uh which is very difficult it's like
now for me maybe also being a woman like
i'm i'm getting a lot of very
kind of exciting propositions
and
i have to say well i love them i mean it
looks really exciting but i really want
i need to make my film i need it
uh and i did for different reasons
because this is what i am this is what i
really want to to tell this is the
my cinema
and for me it's a it would be very nice
if you can combine both meaning i can do
my own stuff writing and in the meantime
while i'm writing because it's a very
long process
i can maybe direct for someone else if i
really like the script or i can go into
a very exciting project
because what i like about
working for example now in gangs of
london in
in the uk is like i meet different
people i meet different crew i i learned
a lot of different things i have i have
never done so i have the opportunity
for me it's like being at school i mean
like they don't know they are paying me
to learn like i'm in school i'm learning
and i'm doing
so uh so i i see all this like a huge
opportunity actually and
and they are happy because i can bring
them something new something fresh
but also i'm happy because they are
giving me a lot of things to work so
it's a win-win
uh so uh when you ask me about my agent
uh
yeah i mean it's interesting i mean to
have an agent and to have especially
because you have someone to discuss
because you can be very
being a director is a very lonely
thing
like people imagine a director
been shooting you know with a lot of
people but this is just like
30 years of 30 days of shooting maybe
but you spend like three years writing
or you spend so much time doing other
kind of stuff so it's a very lonely
process
um
so uh
and sometimes
you you you have doubts you need someone
for the industry i mean they can really
be they can be good company
so you need someone to uh to tell you
you know marcella are you sure you want
to do this or maybe this is a very good
opportunity take the call this is
nice people
so um
i would say is a to to each director
if that's what you want if you really
want to go to hollywood and you really
want to maybe go for this kind of films
well go for it that maybe you need an
agent and you need to go into this kind
of projects
uh but if you are
dreaming about other kind of thing just
don't go i mean you don't need that so
all depends what you want i mean you
have to be very honest with yourself
also and any filmmakers listening to
these i'm sure that they're making notes
as to what you're all saying but kareem
you're a wonderful example because of
course you're about to start
a
film proposed to you by the
indomitable gabitana
so it we the hollywood a actress not one
of you but an elite one michelle
williams
so where do you stand on the hollywood
age and
dance of uh
what do you think yeah listen like you
didn't need it it's
it's an interesting question i did start
many years ago a kid forget
um
about 20 years ago and i did have an
agent at the time
who was a great agent but i don't think
i was really ready to go there just
because i felt i just needed to improve
my calligraphy in the sense of like what
i was doing you know it was my first
film and then it took me a few years and
now i'm i just feel really lucky for a
few reasons i feel very lucky to have
great agents who are around me and
sharing
not only the projects but you know why
you're making this and how do you want
it to be made you know and how do you
want it to be seen and so on so i feel
very fortunate for that and i also feel
very fortunate that they are
sort of not introducing me and starting
relationships like for example they want
to have with gabitana now which was you
know who was introduced to me by an
agent by my english agent sophie dolan
so
i think it's just um it depends as
marcelo said um on what you want to do
but i do think as i was talking about
platforms before that
i feel that we live in a time that we
have access to different possibilities
and i think it's really great to think
about
that as a privilege because i think a
few years ago
that wasn't the case and i think i feel
very fortunate that i can do a movie
here in the uk and i think it's also
great you know i think it's a tradition
of foreign directors making films about
you know english stories and i think
it's really great to be able to be part
of that sort of legacy but at the same
time
i feel that i can and i will be making
films in brazil again so i think it's
um it's really great to be able to have
choices and i think that's what's really
wonderful about um the position i mean
now and and
the world that we're living in so i
think the agents
can be and they are great to help you as
marcelo said as sounding boards and also
people that help you
sort of navigate that world and then
also they're very um
they're just you know there's something
really
beautiful about that relationship that i
never had before
but also they're great in the sense of
connecting with producers that you are
going to have long time in relationships
um so it you know it's sort of a
matching game which i think it's always
really um
really exciting and i also feel like
it's not anymore about making a choices
of making film here or there i think you
can make
films in different parts of the world
and you can always go back and make
films in
originally where you come from for
example i don't think i'll ever stop
making films in brazil in portuguese and
i think it's great to be able to
to have the option so i think um
it's just a really interesting moment
where also i mean and i think this has
always happened but i think it's
happening more and more i think marcelo
said something really exciting which is
about you know we are the kings and
queens of improvisation i think
in latin america you never know what's
going to happen tomorrow you know so i
think
we need to improvise all the time and i
think that gives you a muscle and a
certain you know sense of poetry that
you have to exercise every day and i
think
i think for the you know for the
mainstream it's really important to have
us as well you know i think that we are
bringing a new breath we're bringing new
electricity we're bringing a new way of
looking at things and so i think this is
also
really
important for us to to acknowledge and
for everybody to acknowledge you know i
think it's really
it's really fun to bring some chaos into
the order and i think it's really fun to
learn some order you know to sort of
you know deal better with chaos and i
think this is really i don't know i just
find it really exciting to be able to
have choices you know when i was
beginning to make films and i actually
like myself i never really planned to be
a filmmaker it sort of happened
i did a documentary then did a short
film and then i needed to do
the portrait of madame satan which was
my first film so i think
thinking back i mean i think we're very
isolated and i think what's really
wonderful about what's happening
at the moment is that
we somehow can have more choices and i
think
the other thing that i think it's really
important to talk about it here for me
making films has always been
a political
act you know like making films and
choosing the characters that we're going
to portray in choosing the way that
we're telling stories has always been
about change has always been about
inclusion has always been about you know
um it's never been only about
entertainment and i think this is what
also has been really great
um in this dialogue that it is you know
i think
we never made a film in latin america
that we just wanted to make it we needed
to make you know and i think this energy
is something that i think it's really
something that will never be taken from
us you know and this is um this is
profound
and if i may pick up of course there's
something we haven't talked about this
there is a history of cinema behind all
of you i i was dying to ask a bit
earlier to gerardo i'm sure that in the
case of miss bala
he had the long shadow of vignarito
cuaron and el toro follow him
around in a good way but also sometimes
in a confused way but you know none of
you and it would be quite good referring
to
from bertolucci doing the last emperor
to angry sending sensibility
to the third man there is a long history
of cinema where the nationality
or the passport of the director or the
language was not so important
perhaps the only thing that i would add
and i let you pick up is that
it would take 10 years between those
films or 20 years
the diversity that we now have in terms
of women genre and diversity culturally
is much more frequent than the isolated
case of the last emperor or uh
and sensibility
any one of those people that you really
look up to and think i pick up some well
i mean tips
about this what i would like to say is
um
not at all because i feel when you have
a real process when you are with some
comrades you know that you are gonna do
this uh
this um how you say this um
mischief you are gonna go and rob the
bank and you have your friends and you
are making the plan
i feel
something starts you know you start
dreaming and i feel uh
very early on you start you stop you
know
you stop
dreaming on the earth i feel you start
having real ambitions
and
and i feel
that's when the movie happens so
yeah
you know i'm
i'm very proud of the cinematic
tradition that mexico can give or you
know i bet every country has where
heidel is making his own history in
guatemala but i feel
many other countries also had you know
like
mexico
was highly influenced by the russians
and einstein came to do you know quebec
mexico and he had the cameraman
edo artisa
and he said that he said gave to mexico
the technique like the technique we use
is russian because of that and
i feel it's um
i feel when we were you know working and
we you can be ambitious
well yes i guess um
you get to dream with the other people
how to you know uh you know use the
medium or whatever you are doing in the
with the
with full intelligence with full life
i guess also what we are doing and if
you let me be a little poetic is to
celebrate
life even if we're complaining and we're
being political and we're showing
horrible stuff of our realities i feel
in a weird way celebrating you know
anyone else would like to speak about
some of the people before
you some of the people led the way
heidel who do you look up to
i was thinking about a very
funny thing if we can
tell that funny about the because in
guatemala we we have a lot of mexican
influence
with that russian influence and after
that we had a lot of cuban influence
with their russian influence and i was
just thinking that guatemalan people
will continue saying that artists are
communist so it's
it's a funny thing but but for sure
for sure we had that the two nations
giving out a lot of of
classes to make
and
and right now my last film i shoot it in
co-production with with usa
and it's the same that would that we had
to change
our system
work
system and and at the beginning i was a
little bit
confused because
we had that
latin american system with my french
side
and when the americans came americans
you usa people came to
to me and we started working with them i
discovered that they follow
process
who works very well and processes who
who help
creativity so i started saying but
i understand why they they they work so
well
and and we start keeping a lot of their
processes
to to implement that in our way to work
so
and we start saying at the beginning
globalization is not only to tell
stories globalization is always is true
understand how the other works
and implement a kind of a global system
to to help us take the best of each one
marseilla where are you on this
oh
you know you well you name all the
directors and and i was thinking about
writers like if we have a huge tradition
in latin america
it's writers i didn't know maybe mexican
cinema when i was young but i knew juan
ruleful
and we all read
garcia marquez and cortaza
neruda i mean we came from writers we
tell stories so
uh for me the latin american literature
was very very important and if you ask
me as a filmmaker of course we have ruiz
which is huge and patricio guzman the
documentary carmen castillo of course
and and then well mexican filmmakers
that are younger like
i'm not that young but in a return
and
but when you ask me who influenced me
and do you know my favorite cinema is
russian
it's a
like uh andres vagisnef again i mean one
of my favorite filmmakers and uh and
tarkovsky
uh i like bergman i like another kind of
cinema and and
and i remember when i was
17 at the university
and i had this friend who used to bring
his cinema project projection and and we
saw alice in this in the cities
being vendors i mean he used to show all
these kind of films also
and polanski like
the knight in one of the first films of
polanski and
so live in the water exactly exactly i
remember that experience and i remember
those films so um those were very very
important for me but i was not trying to
copy someone that's very uh or
you learn just i mean i guess the best
school you have just watching all this
film all these stories but all this
story comes from from literature i mean
it's like it's a it's a writing process
now when you write with the camera so uh
for me uh one of
the more exciting moment is not
only the shooting but it's the editing
because i said you you write the film
three times no you write
which is a kind of
guide structure i would say but then
then you make the film one and because
we come from latin america i feel very
free i i i guess well i don't know the
way wes anderson work but i imagine he's
very control freak and everything is
like very very measured and i'm exactly
the opposite
like i'm very free and open and i like
to to tell the actor that they can feel
free or we can practice we can change
things i like surprises
and then i like to in the edit still to
rewrite
this is for me what is exciting to have
this possibility of write rewrite and
and to build the film little by little i
know pablo ryan does the same
like uh he shoots a lot and then he in
the edits he really makes the film so
that's i mean we are very different all
of us i guess and and and that's what is
very nice about cinema and about authors
is like we're all different and we
discover ourselves in a culture
uh and but in the middle of the world
doing all this in in very different
process and i was very curious when
kaido was talking about the things that
he learned working with american in the
american system a little bit with the
american producer like i'm but now i'm
very curious i want to know you have to
tell me
kareem where where are you on this what
what what is influenced you how do you
see who came before you
uh it's so important i mean on my case
it's a little messy you know like i
think i was influenced by
some
i was really influenced but i think some
queer filmmakers like fuzz bender was
really like a big
influence on me but so different though
german you know and i just think why do
i like this work so much but there was
there was an anger there that i really
liked you know and i think also
there was a lot of brazilian cinema from
the 1960s that was really important to
me there was a sense of rebellion and of
like
breaking the rules you know when you
think of how films were made and with
the you know i think a new technology
was 16 millimeter but i mean i was very
influenced by
a lot of those guys from
you know the 60s
and i also was very influenced by soap
operas you know i mean i was growing up
in brazil in like in the soup of soap
operas so
there was something about them that i've
always refused but at the same time i've
always felt you know there was something
that they did to my heart
that i think it was really incredible so
i think it was it was it's a
in and also music i think i was very
influenced by you know i remember that
um
every film i make i mean i it begins
with the song and it sort of literally
ends you know it begins with the song it
says that it's sort of you know it's
what inspires me and it's there's always
a major song you know that i need to
have
at the very end at least so i think
these were um
i think i was i was very fortunate to be
going you know be growing up in a moment
where
there was all these different influences
you know of course i was influenced by
american cinema and especially again i
think the question of music is really
important you know i can never forget
the moment i saw saturday night fever
and the moment i saw fame for example
you know these are two films that
for me were really um were really
fundamental you know the sense of joy
that you have when you are in a movie
theater so this is this i think i know
it sounds like a crazy mix but i think
i've always i've also sort of accepted
to
[Music]
to take on this mix and and make it mine
in a certain way so i think
um
and i'm also very excited now i think we
are in a moment in the world you know
when you think that monkey [ __ ] did
cleopatra and and when i think that you
know now we'll be able to tell the
stories of those people here up north
you know that have always been telling
our stories i think it's also a really
exciting moment in this sense of um
turning the game you know and and and
bringing this sense of you know of
anger rebellion poetry sort of
viscerality that i think we have
it's not only latin american cinema it's
in latin american life you know i think
it is really really it's a really
exciting moment for that reason so i'm
inspired by you know all of this but
also by
this possibility of
telling the stories
of other nations and other countries
which are not ours and how we can you
know how we can
access that place because it's been done
the other way around for so long so it's
really exciting
um to do that as well but i think to
finish this i think what's really been
inspiring in terms of um
of other work yes a lot of russian
cinema a lot of documentary work a lot
of work that i feel it is about a
certain
freshness you know and i don't know
exactly i love when i don't understand
really well how films were made but they
somehow
touched me profoundly so i think these
are the filmmakers that um without
citing too many names that really have
turned me on
before we close so many things we
haven't talked about film schools uh
we haven't talked about many things but
we i feel we could do a documentary
series of like at least six or seven
episodes with all that you have to say i
think what is very moving of what comes
out of what you've said is is a
remarkable conversation to say where
certainly not one i've had before
where the fluidity of genres documentary
fiction television
you are comfortable
and well-versed in so many of these this
is really news even for the inarritu
cuaron
del toro
they did not have this glorious moment
that you have of an opportunity of
moving across of building
milestones such as guatemala from zero
or where you know not only hydro i
should point out he's a filmmaker he's
also building a whole community in a
production house and
and and bringing all sorts of other
filmmakers in it's a unique moment but
because we're looking to the future and
my god you have to give an amazing
credit to music and literature
which undoubtedly you could say the boom
of latin american cinema without the
boom of latin american literature
might have not been the same
but i want to leave you with a gift
we're gonna play aladdin
um aladdin with the lamp and i'm gonna
grant you a wish
because i think perhaps we've been a
little bit serious and all of you have a
wonderful sense of humor
so
now is the moment where you can let your
head down and i'm gonna let you all have
a wish for cinema
obviously we have managed to have this
our conversation without talking about
the death of theatrical cinema
none of you have raised it which i think
is fantastic because as we know
i think for the last 30 or 40 years
we've been hearing the cinema is dead
cinema doesn't die it evolves in
different ways
so one wish
for your own cinema uh filmmaking or for
the good of cinema hyrule i'll let you
start one wish you are being granted
anything you want
oh for money not money
not for sure i have enough
[Laughter]
no for for my own cinema
uh
i mean having the
the freedom to to be a production
productor to i love it
and i love
and i love discover other talents and
right now i'm finished a film that i
produce in argentina
and i and i want to be my producer is
very strange from film director's
filmmaker because normally we don't love
that but i really enjoy both
so that's for mine
and for the global one i will say for
the latin american one
a large distribution between our
countries
and i think we
we can do
very strong things that we start
watching our films with less problems
yeah
marcelo what do you wish for
oh
i guess i i really wish
it's something more general i think with
you know with the pandemia and the kovid
and and cinema has suffered a lot
and
and in paris that we have this a lot of
a lot of
solid cinema
and they have suffered a lot so i i
really i wish all the people can come
back again to uh to take advantage
because
i belong to this city who loves cinema
and
and we have this great tradition and we
in france you have a
large distribution of cinema from all
over the world and
and i remember if i was very proud about
living in paris it's about this you you
go for this small book called you know
official
and you have like 200 different films
it's like that almost weekly so and and
i could just choose and go to the cinema
every day if i wanted i mean i remember
that that those were my years at the
university
and and i enjoyed that so much
and
so i wish that i wish like the new
generation like the new people that now
they are coming back to the university
all these
foreign people coming to my city
could do the same that i that i could do
when i was younger
that i want them to be able to jump into
those cinemas i used to jump into to
watch films
uh sometimes even like uh that i
couldn't understand
and i really enjoy them so
that's a huge experience that's what i
really want and
a return of cinema tech the return of
cinema tech culture we need a digital
cinema tech perhaps
yeah but
what do you wish for
we're asking the impossible so yes uh
definitely i will i will put it in a
different light i will say
you know yes i i wish people will dare
to you know to turn off the cell phone
and get into a dark
room where i feel when you let those you
know
how to say that to the new generation
when you let yourself be
you know completely smashed by a film in
the dark room i feel it's a
experience that um
transforms you you know when you see a
bergman film and you don't move and you
don't check the messages
uh you get out being a different person
so yes i will say that uh
dare to do it
marcella i'm sorry did i leave you
halfway through you had the second part
of your wish yeah but don't worry
oh sorry maybe i can live without that
wish but uh no of course for my own
cinema i won't be able to uh
to do my own cinema to keep on doing
what i like you know to tell my stories
of course we all we all want that and
that's what i wish to all my colleagues
that we we can still be able to have our
own voice
and karim what do you wish for
i wish that there is always a space for
us to take risks to experiment to go a
bit crazy
to not know exactly what we do we know
that there is space in the industry
to diversity really know that we can
keep inventing reinventing cinema i
think it's such a young former
expression that i think
the moment that i see things being a bit
sort of square and you know domesticated
it feels really boring so i just hope
that in the next few years
we don't get more homogeneous but we get
more um diverse
i wish for um
you know the cinema of cinema and you
know that could be a large word
for places like africa you know
southeast asia you know some places that
we don't know much about you know
here in the west that they can know they
can have structures that they can be
making more films i think it's really
important that we it's so interesting
what happened in the academy of israel
with parasite i mean i think it's so
important to have
you know languages which are not
necessarily i mean english is a very
important language but they're really a
lot of languages out there
that us as spoken as english so i think
i just wish for more diversity in this
industry i think we learn so much when
we see
stories that are told in a different
manner than ours and from places that we
don't know so i think we need to be more
diverse that's what i wish for and also
you know and again for more risk
well i think we've come to the end of
the time um to thank you deeply um it's
been an inspiring conversation uh
hopefully the one of many to come thank
you for your time for your insight
um
as the heading of the event says
you are from latin america into the
mainstream you are truly global in every
aspect
all that remains for me to say is
looking forward to seeing what you're
cooking up next
hopefully some of those will be as
you've been before on the international
oscars um
again thanks to diego luna for giving us
also his time for the introduction
uh we'll see you at the movies good luck
with all your projects
and lastly thank you to the spanish
academy in madrid
for giving us some hospitality to do
this event thank you very much marcella
gerardo hydro and karim hasta la vista
you